[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAN GALPIN: Hi, welcome back to
the Developer Show's coverage
at GDD India.
I'm Dan Galpin here
with Sean McQuillan,
and he's here to give us an
update on Android and Kotlin.
So Sean, why start
with testing in Kotlin?
SEAN MCQUILLAN: It's
a great question.
Testing is a great way
to introduce new features
to your code base, and it's an
easy place to try new things.
It's low risk, and
it doesn't require
you to make any production
changes to your application.
DAN GALPIN: So were
there any surprises
in terms of ways you could
use Kotlin to improve testing?
SEAN MCQUILLAN:
Tests are a place
to really stretch the
expressiveness of a language.
And Kotlin really,
really shines here.
We can use extensions, lambdas,
and all of the language
features Kotlin
provides to really push
the limits of our test and
make them absolutely beautiful.
DAN GALPIN: So Kotlin has been
a fully supported language
for Android for
about six months.
You know, what are
the kinds of things
the Android team is doing to
help developers code in Kotlin?
SEAN MCQUILLAN: We've added
nullability annotations
to the support
library in version 27.
That makes it so
Kotlin can safely
call into Java
without introducing
NullPointerExceptions.
We've also added guides for
style and interop with Java,
and we've produced a
lot of Kotlin samples
that are listed on our page.
DAN GALPIN: So what's
something developers
might not think to
do when writing code
in the Java programming
language that
needs to interop with Kotlin?
SEAN MCQUILLAN: One of
the cool things you can do
is make sure that single
abstract method parameter
types are declared last
in your functions, which
allows you to call them using
Kotlin's trailing lambda
syntax.
You should also add
nullability annotations
to all of your Java APIs that
you intend to call from Kotlin.
DAN GALPIN: So what has
been the response to Kotlin
that you've seen
here at GDD India?
SEAN MCQUILLAN:
Everyone I've talked
to has been really
excited, and they've either
started adopting Kotlin
in their code base
or they're looking to do
so in the near future.
DAN GALPIN: So if a developer
wants to learn Kotlin,
what resources
would you recommend?
SEAN MCQUILLAN: They
should check out
the Getting Started guide
on developer.android.com,
and then go to Kotlin link
where there's a great tutorial
about how to learn Kotlin.
You can also look
at the Kotlin cones,
which are short snippets of
Kotlin to learn the language.
And there's two books, Kotlin
in Action, Kotlin for Android
Developers, that are both great
places to learn about Kotlin.
And of course, you should
watch the recording of my talk
yesterday.
DAN GALPIN: Thank you, Sean.
Visit the description
below if you'd
like to learn more
about testing and Kotlin
and check out all of our
additional interviews.
[MUSIC PLAYING]